this is what's left of the education
Ministry in somalia's capital Mogadishu
at least 120 people were killed last
month when two car bombs exploded
outside al-shabab the al-Qaeda linked
armed group claimed responsibility for
this attack and others that keep
happening in the country
journalist Faisal or mahashi survived
last month's blast at the education
Ministry he says people are afraid not
sure when or where the next attack Could
Happen
these explosions aren't new to us
they've been blasts for 10 years people
know usually when one explosion happens
that there may be a second one soon
afterwards sometimes even the third
explosion at the same place
government forces have made some gains
against al-shabab in the last few months
regaining territory long held by the
group
the character Revolt is led by the
community Somali Community the clan is
called maosling Khan militias but the
government are the one who set him date
their strategy and backing up militarily
and logistically so this is the for the
first time in 13 years where it's about
controlled 70 percent of South Central
Somalia we have seen a more than 1 000
kilometer acres of land has been
liberated for mashallah because of the
community backup but the attacks keep
happening some officials say more
coordination is needed between Security
Forces to better protect civilians
we are always Vigilant because we know
an attack Could Happen anywhere and any
time the education Ministry and workers
there were alerted hours before the
blasts occurred but the enemy gained
advantage over us we regret what
happened and take full responsibility
al-shabab has killed tens of thousands
of people since 2006. the group wants to
top of the government and Implement its
interpretation of Islamic law
some animals say defeating al-shabab
wounded more cooperation from Regional
countries in East Africa and the
International Community Center